[Music]
speak of the early days and I won't
repeat again many of the things you've
heard I will say that he's justifiably
recognized as one of the exceptional
experimentals in the field Martin did
seminal experiments the positronium is
his trademark he was a signal figure in
the laboratory beyond his own researches
director during the period of the japes
I excitement
so let me without further adue terms of
Martin an exceptional person as well
it was really impossible to prepare this
to make this talk and I so obviously I
can't give the talk but I'll have to
tell you why I can't give the talk and
that's what I'm going to spend my time
on does somebody know the next line
Vicki
whom did you have in Latin in the sixth
you should know they know clearly I this
is the this is Virgil I think and says
the first age was the golden age and so
I think I'm supposed to speak about what
I am supposed to perceive as the golden
age and I tried very hard to do that and
I said well it's obviously true that the
days of people taught physics as it was
first called in in preparing this was
the the age in which everything was
wonderful you didn't have the
bureaucracy you didn't have to worry
about money you had lots of ideas the
experiments went quickly and so I I was
trying to understand what the basis for
this golden age really was and so of
course I made the model I made the
theory and started working on it and I
concluded that the problem was not that
at least I think the cause was not that
experiments were smaller because I think
compared with the gross national product
they are not that much cheaper not not
that much more expensive or bigger now
maybe one order of magnitude but not
three or four so it had to be people so
it had to have to do with the
interaction between people
and I will at the end of this talk tell
you the conclusion that I reached and
why I can't give the talk but the but I
tried I started out and what you have
here is a time scale because I didn't
want to write that on each of these
pieces of paper so I started out by
saying well what did I do in this time
interval this time interval goes from
1946 true it Peters out somewhere around
1960 and I will tell you why I stopped
about them what I wrote on this first
slide which is not not very important
but to guide me on the time scale was
where I was at some of these times some
of these times and it turned out that I
was away more of the time than I'd
realized I had starting 1946 which is
the year of the Big Bang as far as we
are concerned I was away in 47 48 which
seems in retrospect incredible that I
left here after a year in 52 I was busy
in Washington 53 54 in Paris the other
things that happens that I've marked
here so following the Lamberto of
nuclear science started as a laboratory
for nuclear science and engineering and
in at this point the engineering
disappeared from the progress reports so
something happened here and the work I
was doing was in a group called
radioactivity and cyclotron group and at
this point the cyclotron was no longer
mentioned and here in 1955 something
interesting happened my name appeared in
the progress reports as somebody
responsible for something until then it
was all Bob Evans and that I think is a
clue to what happened in those years I
think Herman Feshbach and I are the only
ones here they go back to before the Big
Bang the I had been I got my PhD here
and the Bob Evans in nuclear physics and
then left soon as I got my citizenship
and could do such things for Los Alamos
it unbeknownst to me the department had
decided not to continue my appointment
here if I'd known that I might have been
a little worried but when I came back
really in a way I picked up where I left
off but something very important had
changed in that time and that was the
status of nuclear physicists they've
been Los Alamos that mean the bomb and
we came back with a feeling of success
in a funny way I think we felt we could
do anything certainly the rest of the
United States thought we could do
anything the description of what
happened when Oppenheimer got off the
plane is quite a quite standard in fact
I remember going to a wash in a washing
meeting in line at the hotel and
somebody says up my mama I'm sorry we
must have lost your reservation or
something we don't have a room and I
said to the man this is dr. Oppenheimer
you do have a room oh yes it went that
way but the real feeling of having
arrived came in 1952 quite late at the
meeting in Amsterdam I you know I tended
not to have my hair cut
as often as I should have now I never
get it cut by a barber I do it myself
but therefore when I went to about a
tour to the Bible to get my hair cut
they usually would say what are you a
musician
and what happened was in Amsterdam I got
my haircut and the man looked at me and
says what are you a nuclear physicist
and that showed that we had arrived but
seriously I think I think that was
probably the real element at least I
thought that was the big element the
other element that made this such an
exhilarating period of course was the
fact at least I thought that we didn't
have to write proposals we didn't have
to to persuade Outsiders that what we're
doing was worthwhile the relationship
with the funding agencies at least
initially was very interesting they
thought they knew much less than we did
I'm not so sure they were right but that
was certainly the relationship the idea
the way the way our activities were
supported was we want to support the
good people to do what they want because
that's the way we've been successful the
physicists there was a feeling the
physicists did in a certain sense
decisive things in the world radar and
the bomb and not because they had been
working on communications or on bombs
that sank in and we were treated with
deference what can we do to help you and
the relations between Washington and the
universities was that the the idea was
that we as as creative scientists were a
national asset and that the purpose of
the operation was to strengthen this
national asset today they it seems to be
that we are contractors and the
important thing is that will assume to
cheat like all other contractors
therefore I have to be be treated in the
same way furthermore we are we
apparently engage in violations of
antitrust laws
maybe we do I don't know I think what
happened later on was that unfortunately
the people in Washington learned too
much they got too good they they knew
too much physics today the power problem
is not that they don't know physics that
they know too much physics they not only
do they think they can make sensible
decisions but they can make sensible
decisions indeed and sometimes they are
right and that comes our style but
whatever it is that was my thinking on
the subject when I came back from Los
Alamos I had a program the program was
that I would work on two things I'm
gonna I'm gonna talk about myself not
because I think it was the most
important thing that happened but
because the experience was a personal
one and if I is not talking except in
substantive context about experiences of
others I only dilute what is really I
think you expect me to to convey I had
two ideas one thing was I'm going to
study nucleus what we today would say
nucleus structure through radioactive
decay processes I've done that before
the war the thing had gone on right into
the war years even done a little bit of
that in Los Alamos and the other thing
that I was going to study was beta decay
or today we would say weak interaction
physics and what I did not think of
although I should have stated it at the
time was of course electromagnetic
interactions in nuclear processes the
funny thing is those were the ones that
turned out the most interesting but I
went back over the nopales reports of
the lab and I found no mention of
electromagnetic interactions took quite
a bit later so I said well I looked
through the records what went on what
did we do what did I do
I don't mean just I by myself but but
what did the physics in my orbit consist
of and the thing that is striking to me
is how many things happened in any given
year so here we have one list the list
it has to do with nuclear structure and
decay schemes and and the subjects more
or less along the time line written in
in green and the black lines the black
ones are the names associated with it
well we did the with the decay schemes
you know energy levels and things like
that by the bushel I you know sort of
every every three months there was a
list of five or six things just to fill
the literature I think that stuff that
today would properly be distributed only
through on computer discs but we
developed an awful lot of techniques
ways of doing things and some of them
were fun one was this business of
studying nuclear angular momenta
essentially nuclear symmetry properties
in of states by angular correlation the
thing that happens when you get back and
read those old papers you see Magna
hardware did I bother publishing this
this is everybody knows that and what
don't forget this that until I published
it not everybody knew it so and I don't
mean that I invented these things so
that I created them out of all out of my
brain they were of course around and
other people were doing similar things
but it was awfully exciting because look
at the time scale in this period of two
years part of which I was away in
Stockholm we opened up cognitions
gamma-ray correlations beta gamma
correlations and only a year so later we
discovered that we could also measure
the polarization of the gamma rays in
that in these processes so all the
things that today you do as a matter of
course we're really quite new obviously
people have done it with optical
optical radiations but nobody's ever
done this with with nuclear radiations
what's really exciting and the other
thing that that is fun in looking back
is the degree to which things that
happened later were really already their
seminal II the very first experiments we
did on correlations between nuclear
radiations I had a chemist as a graduate
student because I said the problems may
well be chemical you see people had
tried to do these experiments but they
didn't succeed they didn't see any
correlations you must remember that the
only radiation detectors one had at that
time where Geiger counters and Geiger
counters are not very efficient
detectors of gamma rays these circuits
are slow you can't use very strong
sources and people hadn't seen the
effect so I said to myself why could
that be the coalition's must be there I
mean that's just the geometry of
radiations and it's clear that they must
be there and I said maybe maybe it has
to do with the atomic fields perturbing
the nuclei and then I had the idea that
wrong that if we could get the stuff
into a gas then you wouldn't have so
many neighboring nuclei and then maybe
you could see the correlation so I got a
chemist who said yes he could make a
gaseous compound of Cobalt
so that we could study the radiations
cobalt for various recovered 60 was a
desirable nucleus to study now as we now
know that was moving the wrong direction
because in fact you're more likely to
have a overall symmetric situation and
therefore no perturbing field in a solid
although maybe not for cobalt but in
general then you have in a gas where the
neighboring atom you know clearly
defines the direction in the molecule
but the idea was there and as I will
show you in a few minutes
the fact that we did this turned out to
be extremely useful at a later point
and then is one of my points that if you
get into physics of a particular area
everything's connected to everything
else well how's that song go the
shinbone is connected to the thigh bone
the faculty it if you you'll learn
physics and it'll come in handy before
long and the other thing that I thought
was maybe if the atoms disturb it maybe
if and puts on an external magnetic
field one can one can overcome this now
those of you are in the field know that
that is true the the important point
about it is I didn't understand it at
all I mean I couldn't have sat down and
calculate it except perhaps just after
ghostly order of magnitudes what would
happen when you did these things did the
experiment anyway and that I think is a
real difference because if I'd had to
build l3 to see whether it's true or not
I clearly wouldn't have right
I do and I think that is is one of the
big differences if one could do you know
in a certain sense I am in experiments
the way Vicky says is in theory lazy
that is the I like an intuitive hand
waving argument and if I do make an
honest calculation I won't let anybody
know it the because it I find it's the
meaning so I I have started many
experiments on what I persuaded myself
was total ignorance because you see
after a few years after we had seen
these initial things indeed other people
worked these phenomena out in detail and
the study of of what happens to to
nuclear orientation and therefore the
correlations of the radiations that I
emitted in the presence of the atomic
perturbation became a cottage industry
and in which we also participated and
there were some very very entertaining
experiments that were done by studying
the crystal symmetry by seeing what
happens to the correlations and the
these experiments of course later were
developed by people who are not ashamed
of doing something carefully and
combined with the most power experiments
and the gardens who sort of took over
from me at the bottom of this page did
some very outstanding work in this
general area now at
there were a number of other amusing
things which I think I'd like to talk
about because they tell you how much fun
one could have with they were some of
these physics one of the things I was
trying to study was the transition
probabilities when you have cascade
cascade gamma rays that is a nucleus
decays in a series of levels what is the
probability of the cross over gamma ray
because Vicki and others had had
developed what was and at least an
incipient theory of of the transition
probabilities and as a incipient in the
sense it one didn't have a detailed
nuclear model to make very specific
calculations but one could in make
general estimates some had already been
in the in the beta Bible but it was
greatly refined in blood and vice squad
and so there were definite predictions
and the idea was maybe we could learn
something about nuclear structure by
seeing what the relative transition
probabilities were so what that involved
was perhaps to look for transitions that
were very rare and a typical example
might be I don't know cobalt-60 where
you have two gamma rays of 1.1 1.3 MeV
in cascade what is the probability of
the cause over gamma ray now you would
think that's easy because you just look
with some kind of a detector it isn't
that easy I don't want to go into into
technical details but there is a way of
making a detector that will only detect
the high-energy gamma ray and that is if
you let it make a nuclear disintegration
which has a threshold that is higher
than the energy you have on the single
gamma rays so what we said is all right
you take Cobalt you put it say with
heavy water then you should get total
disintegration of the deuteron you'll
get some neutrons but how do we detect
the neutrons there'll be very few
and what we did was something that is
known as the Salar charmers process we
go to that about this big and we filled
it with a solution of potassium
permanganate you know the thing you can
gargle with enter now we put the sauce
in the center of that a neutral the
neutron will be captured by the
manganese when the manganese captures
the neutron its oxidation state is
reduced and it is precipitated as
manganese dioxide then we took this big
vat and filtered it and all the activity
was on a little filter paper and that
way you could detect oh one part in 10
to the seventh of gamma-rays I thought
that was a fun experiment because you
didn't have to have to write a proposal
you you did some something new so a lot
of that happened a lot of that kind of
thing went on now in my confused way of
not looking too hard I had a - I had an
idea that and I that and I'll tell you
how I got slapped down properly
I said look electromagnetic and
interaction in beta decay have something
in common I don't know what it is in
retrospect I know what it was I was
talking about at the time I didn't when
I say this look the selection rules are
the same you get the same kind of offer
but it looks like a multipole expansion
and especially if you look at things
like internal conversion you know where
where the energy is not emitted as a
gamma ray but there's an electron from
the shell it really looks very much the
same as far as what we call angular
physics is concerned the only thing is
the charge changes in one case electron
becomes a neutrino in the other case it
stays an electron don't these things
have something in common well I
I said I don't know why they're sure
what it should be I I asked the eunuch
Michigan who was expert on beta decay
and he said to me you don't understand
family theory this is nonsense the
electron neutrino is the SD field there
isn't the field in between like the
electromagnetic field that induces the
transition but the first part of the
statement was correct I did not
understand family theory the second part
of the station statement of course was
wrong because there's a W Z in between
so so much for listening to the
theorists the mogees Gould Harbor said
something that was I think more
constructive he listened and said well I
think that needs to be fleshed out a
little but the idea the idea persisted
and it sort of haunted me until they the
real answer came out and then I had some
real crazy ideas for example I said look
in high-energy beta decays there is
among other processes an electromagnetic
process that creates electron pairs
now that means you've got one more
electron in there I mean the transition
in making the pair for negative positive
energy state and if there really is
something which electromagnetic and beta
decay transitions have in common maybe
you get interference terms Oh totally
totally silly idea now that we
understand what happens but it's let's
try and I didn't have to write a
proposal and it didn't cost me money
just cost the graduate students life so
I don't mean he died I mean he just
wasted his time that was the that was
Jack greenberg who searched for
positrons an anomalous number of
positrons and let's see
Dave peasley I think did the calculation
for know it was cousin Wang who did they
one of the calculation for us but in the
pauses of looking
this this thing we found a lot of other
interesting positrons coming from other
other processes so another case where
misunderstanding the the theory in the
proper way was very productive well I
don't think there is much sense in in
telling you all the detail things that
happened and it was then in 1956
it must be 56 that and one more new
thing happened in in this game and that
was of course when when the parity
violation was was discovered and I
remember being called up unusual hour by
sintering whoo who told me what was
happening which I had heard already from
your hobby and she said look why don't
you why don't you calm down have a look
we can't I mean we believe the
experiment right but we'd like you to to
to look at it and I came down and looked
at the apparatus and and one of the big
problems was in which direction was the
magnetic field you see what's the
elicited positive and negative and I
said how did you check the field she's
well with a compass needle I said you'd
be careful because you can then you can
polarize the compass needle no ago we
did it all right and and it then so then
she said we know I sure come to the yes
the compass needle was all right and I
said okay now tell me one more thing did
you think in Chinese or did you think in
English because in Chinese you say the
compass point south it's just as good a
missus the other hand and she turned red
for a moment it's all right so you see
how careful you have to be in that in
physics but one of the problems that was
left over was the question whether
whether the polarization in a pure
family transition the hilly city will be
the same in later and then now that we
have a theory this is all obvious but we
had a problem left the problem was left
over and we're going to look at the at
the hilly city of positrons in pure
theame transitions and that was an
interesting thing
yeah you know in a social sense I
Maurice kadha Bob and the Guardians had
done this extremely pretty experiment on
the hill isset II of the neutrino in
orbital electron capture it's a real gem
it's one of those those experiments is
it isn't it cute you know this is one of
the troubles my I hate retrospectives I
I just hate them and the reason is
anybody who's ever done an experiment
probably theorists have the same thing
you look back in an experiment a couple
of years later and you know exactly what
you should have done and when you do
that on a large scale it can get quite
painful but anyway the they had the same
idea we had about how one does this this
detection of the hilly city by absorb by
determining the circular polarization of
the annihilation radiation and because
both can do it inclined 34 and Bernie
Gittleman owes graduate student working
on that and so I said look let's not do
something silly because if we are
running a competing experiment that'll
that'll make us publish prematurely and
maybe they'll publish some nonsense
let's keep each other informed how we're
doing and then you know if one of us
thinks he has enough data to publish
he'll tell the other one who can either
and we have to trust each other we are
honest people if he thinks he is good
good enough data he will have a chance
to publish it it's not one publishes
first and we went on now I hopefully
will will check whether my recollection
is correct or whether because you know
all autobiographies are lies because you
only remember what you like and if there
isn't anything to remember you like you
invent it so let me tell you the what I
think happened we both worked on it and
it was pretty miserable this there there
it's a very difficult experiment the way
we were doing it and I
I was quite dissatisfied on the other
hand probably by the way the statistics
worked out the bookkeeping people were a
little more comfortable and it went on
and we both were we're somewhat unhappy
but finally I said look this isn't gonna
converge I said to Bernie let's do a
different experiment let's do it
differently
it's lose a user spectrometer and I
think at the time the there was a it was
not an open-and-shut decision that is I
think the guys in you guys thought you
you had an answer but then we compared
our data we said that's no good and we I
said lovely thing to do is come up here
come to MIT and we'll do the experiment
together and do it right and we did it
and we did it right and it was an
extremely successful experiment because
Lee stayed and that was that's why this
was an important experiment then with
the whole series of other things but now
you say well okay that's nice you have a
spectral lab for nuclear spectroscopy
the problem is that something else went
on in the same time now when I put this
on here you will of course find that you
can't the can't read this anymore
because there's too much maybe you can
some of it can be read the this was we
started working with positrons as you
can understand I I said look there's
positron annihilation and since I had
the crazy idea that electromagnetic
interactions might also involve some
other interaction I said maybe if we
look at positron annihilation we will
discover some other interactions between
electrons in retrospect that's it's
absolutely childish because we know the
mass of the W of the W the Z is much too
high to see in phenomena of that low and
energy but it was fun
so I said let us
I see no reason why these have to be you
see the reason I put these on top of
each other was it they happened on top
of each other and that was the great fun
that was going on all these things went
on in parallel so the first thing I said
well let's see what happens when we the
only we don't really know how strong
they nily the annihilation cross section
had never been measured at least not in
any any meaningful way so let's see what
happens if one measures the annihilation
of positrons in flight and totally
trivial thing you would say today so we
started with it I the student Shira who
who did it first and this thing
continued and was finally done properly
a couple of years later by Henry Kendall
it's interesting you know just noticed
something you put these people together
here these black ones are all the people
that that worked with me so if they see
we got Sigmund Kendall and Rico three
Nobel Prize winners not bad is it the so
we so that was straightened out then but
then I said to Cheryl look this this was
a very good experiment there is a way of
measuring the cross section at low
energies by doing it in a gas because
you calculate the cross section and the
density how much material is it should
just be in the right range for these
many nice things we have developed which
were relatively good time resolution
counters that would allow us to measure
lifetimes in the order of a hundred
nanoseconds which was very fast the time
that should be just about the range and
will tell us something about the
interaction which was of course again
nonsense because you don't have three
electrons you've got the the
annihilation occurs in a very
complicated field the available electron
density is almost impossible to
calculate so I mean it was rather
nonsense but the experiment was
interesting and somewhere around here
reading in the in the progress reports
it says well we did the first
experiments but something's wrong
because whatever the interaction is
after all if you put more gas in the
annihilation must go faster because
there are more electrons and it must go
proportionately faster and then of
course then led the explanation was of
course the in positronium and that then
was a lot of fun but I will not tell the
positronium story again I'm just you
know you give this talk opposed to a
certain number of times and then you you
say everybody must be so bored because
they've heard it so many times so
there's nothing to do it even if
particular people have not seen it what
I do want to show is how fast this knife
went eventually to two areas in one
direction was the the chemistry of
positronium
and there we had a lot of fun as i look
back at the reports that stuff was never
really properly published because i I
couldn't get myself to believe that it
was really interesting
or maybe the Asians were different maybe
there were personal reasons I don't
really know
it was never properly published but the
whole industry has grown up around it I
I see occasionally in the literature
people do experiments that to which we
really had the answers at that time but
you know they I have at times I have
that contempt for chemistry of other
typical physicists at other times I
think the opposite I'm a chemist at
heart but that's where this sort of
didn't go quite as far as it should what
we did instead was to we studied of
course the fine structure which was very
exciting stuff and made a big splash and
as I say I don't want to go over that
again although in some ways it might be
appropriate only one thing that is not
known is that we also tried to look for
the first excited state of optically
excited state of positronium
and that was Henry Kendall's thesis
it's sort of failed probably you can ask
him maybe maybe he saw it maybe he
didn't it was an extremely ingenious
thing it was his idea I was away that
year as I put this thing over it I think
it should show up that I was in Paris at
the time and I have referred to that
several times most recently when an
Italian colleague said that I should
really get a particular student to write
a thesis on something we are doing and I
said look that's not good enough and he
said oh look he will be very happy to
get such a straightforward thesis and I
said no I had two students who at least
two students who turned down a thesis
and offered that they could could write
a thesis on something that already done
because they thought the stuff wasn't
good enough for their daughter's thesis
one was Henry Kendall and the other was
restyling whose name you saw before both
of whom decided to do something more
interesting and I think they when you
get that student who does that you know
you've got a win up all right
I'm now I'm stopping at this point many
things happened after that
but what happened as far as my life is
concerned was among other things that at
that point I became chairman of a
directing committee of the lab the story
was the following
Jerrold Zacharias who had created the
lab decided he had enough and Pete Dimas
who had been designated impact of it as
the s you know the expression the some
time before I was considered still a
little bit too young and people asked me
whether I would become director of the
lab for a few years and I said no I
won't do that but if we will create a
directing committee and I will service
of that committee and I promise never to
call a meeting of the committee and then
they said well why do you want to be
only chairman as it's very simple when
I've had enough if I am chairman I just
say well I guess the chairmanship should
rotate and at the end of it you just
rotate and somebody else does it if
you're chairman you have to say I'm
going to resign as chairman and you need
a search committee and they keep you
there for another year so that was the
reason and at that point so I changed
direction and I decided I also should
get out of the field and went on to do
some high energy physics now I only have
to spend two minutes to tell you why I
mean obvious to you now why I couldn't
couldn't give this paper this talk to
you because it doesn't prove any of the
things that I I wanted to prove and the
reason it doesn't is because the things
that I was saying were false
I said we didn't have to write proposals
but we had to write a quarterly progress
report I said we didn't have to to
struggle for money from Washington I
still don't struggle for money in
washing I mean I've never just like
weekly I've never had the experience of
not getting money for something I really
thought needs doing I think I don't
think I don't think that's a difference
I know now last night I suddenly
realized what the difference really is
why it was so much more exhilarating so
much more fun more I learned it from my
mother
when I was a very young man she tried to
tell me why life was so much better
under the emperor than it was under the
Republic and she said you know people
were courteous there wasn't that much
crime
there was all the people who addressed
that and most important one was so young
thank you